Hello.
Welcome back.
Hello everybody.
Oh god.
I took a couple days off.
I think I had too much fun.
My voice sounds a little funky now.
Sorry.
I sound sick, but I'm not.
Maybe I am.
My nose is a little runny.
Your voice bork.
No!
I'm okay.
Just sick in the head.
So true.
I'm sick in the head, but I don't want to get better.
Have a fun weekend?
I did!
I had so much fun.
I got to hang out with some friends.
Chucky from Rugrats.
A baby's gotta do what a baby's gotta do.
I'm just roleplaying as a sailor.
This is my sailor voice.
Thank you for the super chat.
Welcome back to Dredge.
It's been a minute since I've played.
I'll be honest, I can't stop thinking about it.
I sound like a grandma.
A grandma?
I don't sound like a grandma.
Do I?
No.
Go fish.
You made me play this game as well and now I almost completed the game?
You're further than me then.
Sheesh.
I gotta step up my game, huh?
Not really.
I don't sound like a grandma.
It's been a minute since I've last played this game.
Where's the hat?
Okay, fine.
I'll put on a hat.
I always think it's too big though.
You don't think it covers up the game too much?
Hat.
A fishing hat.
Oh my god, it's huge.
I'll make it a little bit smaller.
Bigger?
How's this?
I keep reading beasts as breasts.
As I walk, no breasts dare make a sound.
Perfect?
Okay, cool.
Oh my gosh, I'm a new PNG Vtuber, everybody.
Hello.
My name is Women Earth.
Because that woman is what makes the earth go round, baby.
I got big breasts.
Probably.
Woman Earth.
What if I kept it like this?
This actually kind of works.
There's a song about that.
Oh baby, do you know?
That's right.
All women make the earth go round.
Oh baby, yeah.
Wait, what is that song?
Close enough?
Okay.
We got it.
I was on the right path though, no?
We're back to Spongebob Squarepants hat.
Heaven is a place on earth.
Because women exist there.
Then, heaven is everywhere.
Baby, women fear me.
Fish fear me and men turn their eyes.
Ooh.
Get one, Minto Patty.
Wait, hold on.
I'm going to try a Spongebob laugh.
Don't laugh at me though.
If I get it wrong.
I sound like I'm glitching.
Hi Eepy and Minky.
Wait, why did I not hear a sound?
I just got back home from my trip and also Eepy finally got to see my Minto plushies.
Hope your voice gets better.
Yeah, it'll be fine in a couple days probably.
Nice sheep impression.
Okay,
can we start the game?
Put the prize in the bag.
Coming right up.
Because you know that's how he does the laugh, no?
He like punches his throat.
I'm like getting choked out over here by myself.
Anyway, continue the game.
Have you never seen a video of Tom Ken-me?
And he does the laugh.
Oostie!
Oh my gosh!
You said and then you so fast got a new job.
Congrats!
Also thank you so much for the 10 gifted.
See?
There was nothing to be worried about.
Congrats!
So happy.
What was we doing last time?
Oh golly, it's been so long.
We have the factory.
Can you believe the size of that squid?
It's shaking the whole damn rig.
Doesn't seem like it should be possible.
The legs are anchored pretty deep.
Saw you on Business Insider.
Nice article.
Thanks Ramrod.
Thank you.
It's embarrassing though.
How's the audio by the way?
Is it too loud?
Too quiet?
Just let me know.
I just remembered fishing.
So true.
Yeah, there was a giant squid in the depths with this thing.
Let's just go swimming a little bit.
And get our bearings.
Hold on, let me look at all this stuff real quick.
Our storage.
We have a bunch of crates.
And we have these research parts.
What were we aiming for?
I wonder.
Generator is always hungry.
I've got no food.
Science lab.
Don't forget the rig still needs some kind of defense system.
I need a defense.
Okay, samples.
What do you want?
Creepy things.
Loot crates.
If only.
Gotta get our sea legs.
Music is super tiny bit louder.
It feels that way for me too.
Gotcha.
I've encountered strange creatures in the... I don't remember if we've read this before.
What do they look like?
Unusual weather conditions.
Sleep deprivation.
They can all lead to auditory and visual hallucinations.
When will I get those?
I already have those actually.
I was gonna say, when will I get the visual hallucinations?
I want the auditory.
You do?
Yeah, I see a snake in my bed every night.
Boss, we need your final say on this debate.
Chicken Minky or Minky Jockey?
I feel like Minky Jockey sounds better, no?
But, Chicken Minky makes more sense.
No!
It's like hard, because Minky Jockey sounds better, but Chicken Minky makes more sense.
Chicken Minky, Chicken Minky, Chicken Minky, Chicken Minky.
Chicken Minky gang.
Oh, wow.
Chicken Minky.
This is a heated debate.
Minky Jockey sounds nasty.
Why?
Ordering a Chicken Minky at the fancy restaurant.
Okay, fine.
I'm convinced for the Chicken Minky.
Minky Jockey.
Do we need to choose one?
I guess so.
Wouldn't it be great to have full sensory hallucinations?
It can't be Minky Jockey, because Minky is not the one being jocked.
Wait, what does that mean?
Is a jockey not a...
Apparently, people make so much noise during the Chicken Jockey scene theaters had to put out.
I heard that!
You guys, I'm so sad.
I was supposed to go see the Minecraft movie on Friday.
And my friends and I, we did not have time.
I was like, girls, pack your florals.
We're going to the Minecraft movie.
And actually, earlier, just earlier, I watched the Red Letter Media video about it.
I thought a jockey was...
Like a guy who plays sports in high school.
No.
That's just a jock.
Wait, what's a jockey then?
There's this one guy on TikTok that made a song...
In the tune of...
What's it called?
I think Imagination from...
From Willy Wonka.
And I can't, I literally cannot get it out of my head.
Minky's straight jocking it.
Oh, like a disc jockey.
Horse rider.
I was like, not a disc jockey.
But it goes, Flint and steel.
Chicken jockey.
I am Steve.
I can't stop singing.
It's been like two weeks now.
I don't know when it came out.
It's been stuck in my head for so long.
I am Steve.
He's like, I place blocks...
And do shit.
I don't remember the words.
Now that I sing it, it's gonna get stuck in your head too.
Brain worms acquired.
I know.
Flint and steel.
It's the way he sings it, because he sings it in very much a way that Jack Black would sing it.
So it's like, Flint and steel.
Chicken jockey.
I am Steve.
I'm sorry.
Waiter, more Minecraft TikTok songs.
No, please.
I need to recover.
Thank you for the ping.
I got to go to the Minky cafe.
I saw that was a thing.
I had so much fun yakai-ing it up on my birthday.
Could I get a chicken Minky pure imagination?
Chicken happy birthday.
Happy birthday, Phantom Knight.
I am Steve.
I miss your birthday, but...
You were jockey...
On the dance floor.
Happy birthday.
Did they sing you happy birthday?
If not, I'm gonna possess them.
And make them do the Spongebob laugh.
You were gonna say murder, weren't you?
No!
I would never.
Okay, so we're trying to get samples.
Sorry, we are playing a game, aren't we?
This thing.
These things.
I wonder where they are though.
Help me.
Help me, scientist.
I miss this.
I was gone for three days.
The laugh where you choke yourself out?
Yeah, pretty much.
That's what I'll do if they didn't sing you happy birthday.
Phantom Knight.
Too long.
Do you know anything more about the prehistoric fish I found?
Nothing useful, aside from confirming with some peers that they are indeed species that were previously thought to be extinct.
There's even a special name for that, you know.
Allosaurus taxon.
A species seemingly raised from the dead.
Just like me.
Three days is like three years.
What are you, a cat?
Actually, maybe not a cat.
You're like a...
A dog?
Meow.
Welcome back, Minky.
I missed you.
Thank you.
Maybe a dog.
Oh, stop saying meow.
Say woof.
A little bark?
Or a big bark?
Some wisps may be cats or dogs.
Do you think I act more like a cat or more like a dog?
Bow bow.
Like a cat?
I'm a cat.
In what way?
Depends on my mood.
A fox?
Are you saying I'm sexy?
I'm faxy.
A dog.
Let's just go around town and...
Oh, okay.
Get my bearings straight a little bit first.
So this is how we change stuff.
Atrophy.
Banish.
Let's just stick to haste for now.
Let's see what we got in the cabin.
Our map says to go.
Oh, this is the...
The Antarctic.
My favorite part of the movie was when Chris Pryce stepped out of the shadows and said, I'm assembling a team for a smashing fun time.
And it's Jack Black in the envelope.
Wait, did you guys... Okay, this is actually kind of spoilers though for...
For the Minecraft movie, but did you see that...
The post-credits scene?
Cat most of the time.
Dog when you see a cute girl or snakes, but...
I mean that was my wife's birthday.
She's a big fan.
Happy birthday, wife!
Our wife.
Happy birthday to my wife.
Happy birthday, my wife.
Happy birthday!
Guys, I'm actually so... Don't remember where to go.
Shoot.
What is this for?
Is this a...
Is this crates?
Maybe?
I think we went to... Gale Cliffs.
Maybe we now need to go to the Stellar Basin.
Check the quest log.
You are so smart, Reina!
Where is that?
Oh, pursuits!
Search for relics, catch rare fish.
Well, that's the long haul.
New fishies are in Stellar Basin.
Jurassic, thank you!
So I was right.
I was headed the correct way.
Yes!
This way.
No?
I'll get there.
Monstruo!
Thank you for the 10 gifted.
Sorry, 10 bucks.
Oh my gosh.
Sorry, I'm so tired.
Speaking of catchy songs and ocean travel, I listened to Epic.
Over the weekend, it was great re-listening to you sing one of the songs.
I hope you'll sing more in the future.
I will try.
Sorry.
A whale!
I want to get more crazy so we can get some giant fish.
I have to listen to Epic.
Sorry, I'm going the wrong way.
I was a whale of a good time.
You both said the same thing.
Right next to each other.
That's so cute.
Hive mind.
More Leviathan!
I want that.
I want more Leviathan.
Right click for boost.
Sink.
The sky is clearing up.
Fish more like a mince.
Get it?
I don't.
Also, FatGuru, thank you so much for 6 months.
If you're FatGuru, do you say I am FatGuru?
Or do you still just say I am Guru?
Can I catch this thing?
Let's try.
We did catch him.
And we got a fancy one.
Trophy, baby.
Let's try another one.
My reflex is still working.
I'm so sleepy.
I'm too good.
Okay, we got one.
Nice.
I am Groot.
Oh my gosh, I went to Tokyo Disney.
This is the last time I was in Japan, obviously.
But on the Small World ride, they had it as a collaboration with Groot.
And he would just sometimes be in the ride and he would like...
He was kind of ruining it because they'd all be like...
It's a small world after all.
And then Groot would just be like...
Oh no, he would go...
I am Groot.
Just in the middle of the song.
And I'm like, why are you here?
I really want to clean up this sludge so bad.
What is it?
Oh, I don't have the abyssal.
No!
We have to go.
We have to leave.
We need to leave.
Why do you hate Groot?
I don't.
I don't know him.
I don't know that guy.
We've already done this one.
I went away so this is late, but congrats on your win and you're back.
Thanks Avril!
You're just in time.
What are you talking about?
It was only a few days ago.
Flint and steel.
Chicken.
Jockey.
Sorry, I really can't get it out of my head.
Is this thing gonna kill me?
Oh, I don't have the other material though.
I am Groot.
Thanks Vald!
My Krabby Pot.
It's full!
Wait, I picked it up, but I meant to...
Ok, good.
I got it all.
Needs repair.
You know what?
That's good.
Now it's in my head.
I'm sorry.
I really can't get it out of my head.
Sea slug.
Is that what I needed?
One of them, no?
Yeah, he did ask for a sea slug and the eagle...
Well, we'll sell the good eagle shark.
Right?
It's not so much of a difference, maybe.
Thanks for the saving though.
Thank you!
Check your quest.
Yes.
Yes, check my quest.
Eagle shark.
Sea slug.
Tripods.
Bitter fish.
Check yourself before you wreck yourself.
My ship?
Before I wreck my ship?
What is that?
Oh, tuna.
Ok, fish market.
Let's sell.
I forgot I'm pretty rich in this game.
Ok, so sell the good eagle shark.
Right?
How do you say that?
Spitter fish.
There's a spitter.
There's a little spitter.
And we'll sell... Wait!
The blue crab...
That buddy can make ink, no?
Or like, we can paint our ship, no?
Inky.
You need a special one.
Wow, we got a lot of sea slugs.
When do these guys become the hot stuff?
Medusa.
And...
The aberration crabs.
Thanks guys!
You guys are gonna be helping me a lot.
I'll probably be asking a lot of questions.
Thank you guys.
Oh my gosh, thank you for the 50 gifted.
What the heck?
Why?
Why, why, why?
Since it's been a minute since I've played.
I won't go crazy immediately.
But it is all coming back to me.
A little, a little at a time.
Is there anything?
Ok.
Confused wench.
I don't think we have...
Oh no, we do!
This, wait...
Wait, is this?
Is this?
No.
It doesn't have the little...
The uppies.
I think I need to go back.
Maybe.
What is this?
Increases... Oh, this is the rotation thing.
1, 2, 3, 1, 2...
Oh, if I wanted better light.
See, it's like, thank you for the 10 gifted.
Thank you!
No uppies.
Yeah, no upgrade.
I think we need to go back.
If I sleep, these guys should still... I don't know, they might be ok.
But they are just samples, so...
Ok.
I was promised uppies.
You were lied to.
Oh, this needs to be repaired though.
Ok.
Repair off.
Ta-da!
We'll...
Sleep.
Colin, welcome to Mumbo's shop.
Thank you.
We'll sleep.
We'll undock.
We'll place our Krabby Krab pot...
Similarly to where it was before.
Wait.
No.
How do I put it down again?
Oh wait, I think it's in here.
Krabby Krab pot.
There we go.
I am here for uppies.
You've come to the wrong place.
You've been...
Oh, that's atrophy.
Been...
Teleport.
Yeah, actually... Wait.
Yes.
You're so right.
Let's teleport.
And...
We go over here.
Oh, it makes us a little crazy too.
Wait, that's so awesome.
Minto isn't tall enough to get...
I am tall.
Learn.
What was I going to go here?
Hold on.
Sorry.
I had a...
Wait, I didn't put down my Krab pot.
What did I put down?
I think I got mixed up.
I'm okay though.
We'll just go to the scientist.
Oh, I had two.
Let's put another one over by...
The...
What's it called then?
Oil rig.
Just somewhere, you know...
Taller than what?
Taller than...
You, obviously.
You want one in the center, like here?
Pot.
Seems like the center.
Maybe I should have checked the map.
Ah, pretty center.
I got him.
Like morrow center.
That's fine.
I like the way he looks.
Very cool.
Four months.
Mint was beaten.
Thank you for four months.
Thank you.
Both DLCs.
I do have both DLCs.
Yes, indeedy.
Nice teeth.
I like the eyes on this thing.
Looks like me when I'm crazy.
Okay, science lab.
Submit samples.
You.
And you.
Now we need the...
And then, okay.
So now we go to the lady.
The factory.
And we get...
This thing must be the infused hoist.
Right?
Wait a second though.
I feel like the other shop it said infused hoist.
Am I crazy?
But it didn't show the little upgrades on the side.
Check out her cheek bones.
I know, dang.
From storage.
Do I have one?
Fathomless winch.
Thank you.
And then...
Oh, we need to go get some goop.
We need the goop.
I need to put on my siphon trawler.
And we gotta goop it up, baby.
You guys prefer like a...
For me, I don't have cheek bones.
I just got cheek.
But I mean, I'm a ghost.
I don't really have much bone about me.
Which do you prefer?
Cheek bone or all cheek?
Hi Minto.
Hello!
Depends on the cheek bone.
Boneless.
Which cheeks?
Oh, true.
You decide.
Ghost to Mint, what you blushing for?
What are you guys blushing for?
Okay, let's...
Let's switch out our net, unfortunately.
And put that in storage.
And then we take...
What's the goop, man?
Oh, this is our goop.
And we install you.
And we...
Is there anything else we can install while we're... You know?
We got a little bit of extra space.
No?
Magic.
The generator craves food.
I forgot to get my fish out the net.
I do that every time.
You're real cheeky, Minto.
You're a real...
Taquito burrito.
Minto cheeks are always peak.
You do too?
I always forget to get the fish out the net.
We even got that special tuna.
So sad.
Oh well.
I'm pretty rich right now, I'm not gonna lie.
I don't think I really...
I don't think I need it, maybe.
So much.
Okay.
What is that?
Can I put this thing down here?
Let me see.
Oh no, it goes in the light.
It doesn't... Let me try.
I can... Can I just put it... I can just put it anywhere.
Wait, so then if I...
Wait, I want the big light.
I didn't realize.
If you reinstall it, the fish will still be in the net.
Really?
Thank you, Fluffy.
And then at this point, they shouldn't be...
Rotten.
Sorry.
I haven't sneak... Oh no.
That was the one, right?
Oh no, they're gone.
No, they're not there anymore.
Sad.
I've been sneezing so much recently, I don't know why.
Bless you.
Thank you.
Oh, it might be the pollen.
You're so right.
My allergies.
You mean someone's talking about me?
What are you, obsessed with me or something?
Okay, let's go get some goop.
The closest goop is around the steel point.
We'll go there.
A dolphin.
Oh, nope, orca.
Minto fishing stream is perfect for my birthday.
Retry.
Is that how you say your name?
Retry?
Excited to be the one...
Excited to the...
Fear fish in action.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear retry.
You might want to retry your message.
No, just kidding.
Happy birthday to you.
Really living up to the name.
Mint,
why did you change your profile picture?
Mint, are you obsessed with me or something?
It's just because I...
I'm better with profile pictures than I am with, like...
Names, you know?
So I recognize profile pictures more than names.
The one... Wait, the one the fish fears is how I'm...
I got you!
Wait, trawl net.
Here we go.
Lower.
There we go.
Collect!
Collect, collect, collect.
Collect.
Collect, collect.
Yummy, yummy.
Goop.
How many have I gotten?
Zero?
Okay.
Goop goes up.
Goop stonks are...
Oh no!
We got the goop.
We got gooped, we got gooped.
Okay.
Oh, I realized we have this little slug on here.
Uh oh, crab?
You're stale.
Mint obsessed with us for real, for real.
I tapped out for a sec.
Did you say the fish weren't in the net anymore?
If so, I'm sorry.
They usually were whenever I accidently...
They weren't, but it's okay.
You don't need to apologize.
I feel worse when you send a super chat to apologize.
I'm not gonna lie.
Wait, nothing equipped.
Wait, I haven't made... Has it been sucking?
Oh, it's sucking.
Wait, why am I...
There we go.
It's sucking alright.
Okay, we're good.
Watch out, watch out.
No!
Got me from behind.
Oh, special, special, special.
What's this one?
Alright.
Wow, he's cool.
What are you saying?
What do you mean?
What are you talking about?
What am I saying?
Oh no.
Let's go to sleep.
Wait a second.
This is fabric.
Which one is the fabric one actually?
I don't remember.
This is the fabric one.
We gotta get all our upgrade supply stuff, baby.
Depleted.
Spooky rocks.
Do we still need cloth?
Do we not?
I don't have any.
I feel like we always need materials.
No?
We did get the one net that scoops up the materials though.
And then we got...
Oh, our net.
Okay, we have one thing of dark canister.
Oh, no, that's not what I meant to do.
Let's sleep and we'll keep scooping.
I apologize for absolutely nothing.
Okay.
We'll just keep scooping up this goop.
And maybe... Because, I mean, we're gonna need it in the future anyway, so might as...
Might as well.
What does this thing do?
The
music in this game makes me so...
Like I just wanna... Makes me wanna yawn.
Okay, that was close.
What's that sound?
What's happening?
I'm in trouble.
Haste.
Leave me alone!
I'm trying to scoop!
Oh my god.
Down.
There we go.
Nice.
We'll just have it out in case that happens again.
Why am I crazy?
Yeah, can't a woman scoop in peace?
This is just...
Stuff like this though, it's kind of like... It's very Power Wash Simulator-esque, you know?
So it's just kind of like satisfying to go through and scoop and...
You know?
Just feels good to scoop it all up.
Like reverse Splatoon.
Splatoon is also very satisfying though, no?
You know?
What do you think?
Wait, I think I missed a spot.
I did the tiniest spot.
Oh my god.
Okay, I think we got it.
Mario Sunshine.
No, I haven't played that one.
I was never a Mario...
Person, you know?
Never really got into Mario.
But maybe now, I would probably be more.
Just, you know, as a kid I never really played any of them.
Astrobot is Sony Mario.
I know, but Astrobot is so cute.
I can either play as a cute robot or a fat old man plumber.
Actually, both of those sound pretty appealing.
You know what?
Let's take it back.
Mario cute.
He is a cute little guy, I agree.
He is a cute little guy.
I mean... Wait.
Where did all the goop go?
I think I'm in trouble.
Wait.
Oh, there's goop.
I'm scared.
Where did the goop go?
There was like way more goop, no?
Mario is canonically 25?
It's literally that meme...
Where it's just like how the youth see old people, right?
Where it's like you hit 25 and it's just like you're just a grandpa.
Wait, I didn't scoop all this up, no?
I'm so confused right now.
Did I really clean this area?
It's all gone.
Okay, well we got two.
Three!
Never mind, let's go.
For an episode of the deadliest catch, this mid-mid captain is using some strange methods.
I'm a better scooper than I realize.
I guess so.
Wow.
This is my birthday.
Epic carrot!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, epic carrot.
Happy birthday!
Hold on, I want to check on my crabs here.
This is my crab?
No, this is my crab.
Bunch of stinking prawn.
Shrimp.
We're feasting tonight.
Good morning!
Fish love Minto and women fear her.
Thanks Lilette for 5 bucks.
Thank you.
I love any time you pop up because I love seeing your OC.
Oh, I've been trying to keep a record of where all that dark liquid has been showing up.
Come see me if you need.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're good, we're good.
Factory.
Alright, let's make an infused hoist.
Throw those in storage.
Oh, I put that in storage.
Next, we take you and we put you in storage.
We uninstall you into storage.
We take... wait.
Wait.
Oh, oh well, yes.
And it also needs repair.
But we...
Infused hoist.
This has gotten so complex.
I know, right?
I think we can switch out this.
Or we can have both, but we'll switch it out.
We'll switch it out.
Uninstall.
To the storage.
You...
Here?
Keep the sucker.
We can come... We can get it back later, no?
Ew, where'd you come from?
Oh, oh, it's rot.
Oh, that's gross.
Goodbye.
Okay, now we'll just sell the rest of the stuff.
That was my sea slug, I know.
Now we gotta go back to...
The place.
We gotta go to the place.
The Stellar Basin place.
Azaeo, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Poor sea slug.
He was so long forgotten, that poor guy.
Bikini bottom.
Thank you.
Dropping my net.
Dropping.
There we go.
I install it and then I forget to equip it.
Hello, hello, hello.
Stellar, stellar.
Basin.
Yes.
A whale.
The whales love me.
The fish fear me, but the whales love me.
They're always around.
Rye has a noose?
We need to craft it.
Let's get some freaky fish here.
Woo!
This is the guys.
Ok, I'm gonna sing an old shanty for you all, ok?
Flint and steel.
Chicken jockey.
I am steel.
Wait a second.
I knew it.
My birthday was Friday.
Celias!
Sorry for a belated birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Celias.
This thing we need.
The spitter fish.
They fit almost perfectly.
They're just a little bit awkward.
Ok, so we needed that and then...
Oh, I thought it was night time.
Oh, it is night time.
We needed that and then we also needed...
This thing.
Where do I find that?
My birthday was in September?
Hush hush.
Is it a night guy?
Angler.
Firefly.
Eagle shark.
Spitter fish.
Nice to see you.
Saturday is my birthday.
Can I get a happy birthday?
Christian!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday Christian Fernandez.
Happy birthday.
Thank you everyone for the appropriate time.
You don't give him the satisfaction everybody.
What's in here again?
This looks like scrap.
Yup, that's some scrap alright.
Alright.
Check out all this.
I'm wasting time a little bit to see if we can get...
Eagle shark.
Spitter fish.
Angler fish.
Is there anything else?
Oh, there's more.
Oh, I'm a little stuck.
Wait, I'm actually stuck.
Okay, we're okay.
Over this way.
Oh, here we go.
Over yonder.
What are you?
Oh, I think that's it.
We're gonna have to be careful though guys.
It's pretty far.
We're gonna have to be careful guys.
I'm scared.
It's far.
There's no one close?
No one closer?
Doesn't seem to be the case.
Waiting for that to burst?
Oh, come on!
Ah, stop!
I've never experienced that before.
Wait, that was new.
Oh wait, that's this guy right here though, no?
Yeah, that's the thing we need.
Tentacle.
Oil tentacle.
That's new.
No!
Please!
Oh,
maybe he just oozes me.
Okay, nevermind.
Okay, I'm gonna get it for real.
Gosh dang it.
I'm getting out of here.
This sucks!
No!
Oh no, my...
My light...
My light got... I know what to do here.
I know what to do here!
Bye bye!
Tactical retreat?
100%?
That could have been pretty bad, you guys!
That was almost pretty bad.
We'll repair Adam.
At the oil rig.
Close call, very...
Stinking tentacles though, man.
But we got everything.
I always forget that you have banish.
I think it's because I don't know what it works on properly.
But yeah, I do also forget to have it.
You don't like banishing demon fishes?
It's not that I don't like it, it's just... Oh my gosh, why is it all prawn?
Oops, sorry about that.
I just forget.
But also, I keep thinking I can use it on the mist and it doesn't work.
It's not meant for the mist.
It works on chicken jockey.
Chicken jockey, I am Steve.
We got another Leviathan!
You can see him real good!
Only one that saw him.
Or only... That looks like a baby.
Godzilla.
I just ran into the thing and damaged my horn.
I think it's a tech lab and all that.
Let's give these first.
It would have been so sad if they had fallen out when I messed up there.
It's just his head.
The music gives slight Harry Potter vibes.
I can hear it.
Professor Layton.
Did you guys see we are getting the new Professor Layton?
That was also in the Switch 2.
It looks so good.
Not my kind of game.
That's okay.
I'm much more of an Ace Attorney girl over Professor Layton.
But I still like Layton when I play it.
Angel!
Thanks for the gifted!
Kept as Layton.
The difficulty is in reading it.
Don't forget, the rig still needs some kind of defense.
How do I build a defense?
What does he want me to do actually?
Quest log.
Continue to assist the construction.
Talk to the researcher about the defenses.
Okay.
Defenses.
Research.
Her?
No?
You're the engineer?
Researcher.
Tech lab?
No, you're an engineer.
You have to talk to the lady scientist at the research facility.
Yes!
That's right.
They said that it was his assistant.
And he sent her away.
My bad.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Thank you.
Okay, so we do have to go all the way back.
To the Stellar, Stellar Basin.
Thank you.
I was just like, where is she?
And we can see her place literally.
Do you see that teeny tiny light?
Can you see it?
If you squint.
Did you fix the ship?
I surely did not.
Lunova, you saved us.
Holy cow.
While you're down that far south, how far along are you in the polar region?
Like nothing.
I've done nothing in the polar region.
I looked around it a little tiny bit and I think I did one thing, but...
Check the new upgrades.
Would it be under factory?
No.
Upgrades what?
Under research?
Under market.
Repair all please.
Thank you.
Factory tier 3.
I don't think we...
Factory...
You
guys are such a big help today.
Thank you.
We're making good progress on getting the factory fully operational.
Tier factory 3.
Guys, remember when like on the 3DS...
Each game would like make a little sound and rune factory 4 would go...
Rune factory 4.
Fisherman, I think you're going to like what we can make here now.
You can make a whole repair kit.
Or a harvester's repair pack.
Or some tea.
Maybe this one's kind of good to have.
This one might be...
This one might be good to have on hand.
Rune factory 4.
I think we can make it.
It's a little late but...
When hovering over buttons you would make a sound and you could spam it relentlessly.
Yeah, so fun.
My light is on.
I don't know if I'll play the new rune factory though.
Not so much played it before.
Not a ton.
There might have been a repair kit already in my... Wait.
I'm gonna...
I'll figure it out.
Oh, the mist.
I think I was going the right way.
It feels... No, it's way too far over.
I'm like, it's gotta be like right in the middle.
The mist.
Brave Minto.
I just feel like it's a waste of time to go back to sleep.
I think we can make it.
The mist.
What is that now that I think about it?
What is that over there?
It's marked but I'm not quite sure what it is.
Go
towards the light?
Is it the fortress?
Mysterious.
Wait, it is.
Why is... I'm so confused.
Don't go towards the light.
I had to do this once.
Researcher.
The dog.
Hello again.
What do you need?
Someone from the Iron Haven Corporation sent me.
I didn't expect that name to follow me all the way out here.
Perhaps I was naive of me.
So, what do you want?
Iron Haven Corporation's head scientist seems to know you.
And I know him.
He was the reason I was posted all the way out here so far from home.
He might have mentioned that I studied under him.
But I studied him too.
His theories on nature's cycles were...
...odd.
He never went into much detail but his work had some curious influences.
I heard whispers through the door of his office.
Saw confusing diagrams that lingered in half-erased chalk.
Chalk dust and on torn up shreds of paper.
Never could make much sense of it.
Is the dog chewing on a bone or rolled up paper?
Oh my gosh!
They fixed!
YouTube fixed the raid thing!
Thank you for the raid!
It's black on... Oh my gosh!
It's not white on white anymore!
Raymac, thanks for the gifted!
Yeah, it's actually readable.
Crazy.
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Tell me about the defensive tech you've been working on.
Well, it's the same tech used in that repulsion machine I gave you.
Ducky!
Thanks for the 5 gifted!
Strictly speaking, I wouldn't call it a defense system.
It doesn't interact with anything on a physical level.
You see, Ironhaven's Scientific Communication Division have long been working on...
...projects to further their exertion over the natural world.
Tez himself, CC, KBarn, thank you all for the 5 gifted!
Thank you!
Have I caught anything yet?
I caught feelings.
Glitchface!
Thanks for the 5 gifted!
It's complicated stuff, but essentially they were trying to emit signals to communicate with...
...anything they wanted to, I suppose.
Digita!
Thanks for the 5 gifted!
Yeah, for Snake, obviously.
The tech I've been working on is along those lines.
But instead of a wide spectrum of communication, it attempts to broadcast a single word.
Flee!
Not to be mistaken for Flea, the bug.
It emits the vocalized panic responses of every animal I was able to gather acoustic data for.
That's so interesting.
What else?
We need to protect the rig and its workers.
I couldn't give a damn about the rig or the corporation.
But not everyone there deserves to face the consequences of the corp's actions.
I'll give you some schematics.
I'm sure someone there is smart enough to decipher them and get it built.
Just don't let them think this means I forgive them.
Or that I approve of what they're doing.
Okay, I guess we can ask this too.
They've been constructing a drilling platform.
Oh, and you're helping them with that, I suppose?
Do you have any idea what they're even doing?
She turns away and tries to recompose herself with a few deep breaths.
Of course you don't.
You're just trying to help.
But you've seen what's happened in the water here.
And elsewhere, I imagine.
Okay, we sleep.
Our poor little... Our poor little guy only gets like five hours of sleep.
Our guy is not well rested at all.
The music is kind of mysterious right now.
Oh gosh.
Oh no, the yawning is starting.
I'm gonna see if there's anything worth here.
Oceanic.
Oh, what's that?
I've caught you before.
Anything that I can see that I'm like...
Swordfish over there.
Loose jaw right there.
What are you?
Wait, where'd you go?
Fang tooth right there.
Loose jaw.
Okay.
And then there's this right here.
Barracuda.
Ew, we got some nasty one.
Infected.
Is that gonna ruin my other fish?
I sure hope not.
Maybe I should have done it like in between some of these.
I think it does.
Watch out for the infected one.
Okay, I'm gonna get rid of it.
It's not worth it.
We still have a bit of a ways to go.
Disease.
I'm a little paranoid.
Oh, not anymore.
Took my meds.
Infected fish is also not worth very much.
Oh, good to know.
Good to know.
Here comes the sea sickness.
No, stay strong.
Why did you throw away the yummy one?
It's spicy.
It's got that extra goopy flavor.
Oh wait, what's that?
Wait, what's going on over here?
What is this?
This is what the wind is leading me towards.
Wait, is this a piece of the treasure map?
It's just a stinking flag.
What's this?
Oh, here we can dredge some of these.
Flag, let's go!
Oh boy, the flag committee is here.
The flag fan club.
What the?
How?
Wait, how did that...
How did he rot?
Wait, my special guy.
He rotted.
No, from the infection.
No, it was too late.
Ouch, it was too late.
No.
That sucks.
There is something else right here.
I think it's more crates.
I think we are good for now.
Thank you so much.
For the pink.
Thank you, thank you.
Me fear fish, women fear mint.
Fish fear chat.
Oh, we have defenses now.
Alright, before we do that...
Let's just go to the generator and we'll sell our...
We got a good amount of stuff in there.
Throw these in storage.
That too.
Sell all our stuff.
I'll even keep the rot in storage.
Someone said to keep it, so...
Put all this on the bottom here.
Like so.
It could be neater, but that's fine.
I fear women.
What you fear is the unknown.
That's why you fear women.
Maybe once you know a woman's touch...
You'll be okay.
Harsh.
Did you finish all ship upgrades?
What do you mean?
What kind of upgrades?
What upgrades are we talking?
Yeah, probably.
Me don't mean...
Damn, we don't...
I'm just saying that a lot of people fear the unknown.
Like the ocean.
And women.
So this is where we're going to build some sort of machine to repel those tentacles, right?
That's what the scientist said.
We have the stuff.
Oh my gosh, we're so good at this game.
Construct.
We'll get started.
Yes!
Defenses are primed.
Turning them on now.
This should better work.
The droning voice begins to sound from the top of the rig, reverberating through the metal down into the deep.
What is it saying?
What do you think it's saying?
I think this is going to make him more mad, no?
It worked for now.
Flee.
Yeah, it's saying flint and steel.
Chicken jockey.
This guy here, what's this game about?
Basically, it's like a mysterious...
It's like you're a mysterious fisherman.
Well, you're a regular fisherman.
And you fish mysterious things.
Mysterious fish.
Minto, please.
I'm sorry.
Wouldn't you also flee if you heard that song?
My viewership just crashes.
Flint and steel.
Chicken jockey.
I am steel.
OK, I'll stop.
Close tab.
No!
Come back!
How can I make it up to you?
It's the ultimate repellent.
The defenses are operational, emitting a droning sound that grates at the ears.
Oh, see, exactly!
That's what I was doing.
Do you also fear women?
Sometimes.
Cloth and scrap.
Fish and jockey.
Oh, who the hell are you?
Outside, the foreman is in conversation with a recent arrival to the rig.
A stern looking man in a suit.
He looks like Vincent Price.
But sir, the sea floor here, it shouldn't be disturbed.
This whole rig is built on some kind of living fault.
You have to trust me.
Trust you?
You, who couldn't even keep shipments in order?
Who involved locals just to save your own hide?
The foreman cowers behind a clipboard.
You who put this whole operation in jeopardy!
I will forgive you if you do a shanty karaoke stream.
I don't even know any shanties.
I could try and learn some.
Enough of this.
Your concerns end at steel.
Your end at steel.
And scaffolding.
Don't do it, me.
Just a little bit.
As a treat.
The future of this corporation is for me alone to decide.
Fire it up.
The drill descends once more into the blackness under the rig.
I hope this guy gets eaten.
This movie is going to ruin us.
I'm sorry!
It's not even from the movie.
That's the worst part.
Oh no!
The man in the cert turns... assert?
The man in the suit turns to you.
And we're back on track.
While he overstepped his corporate responsibility...
It appears the foreman was right to enlist your assistance.
Yeah, the music is getting a little faster, James.
There's one final building that needs to be constructed on this platform.
Sorry, it's not Flint, but it's so close.
Fleet Services.
Without this building, we're unable to scale our efforts efficiently.
Ribby!
Thanks for the bread!
Ribbit.
Raymac, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Thank you for the 20 gifted!
Thank you!
Thank you guys so much for the bread.
Hello, hello.
How goes the dredge?
It's fine!
How was your stream?
Thank you so much for the 5 gifted!
Pugmug, thank you for the 5 gifted!
Oh my gosh, stop.
That's so stinking cute.
Oh my gosh!
You are a pugmug!
That's so cute.
And then even your emoji is a pug and a mug.
Okay, Martin, thanks for the 5 gifted.
I got to play Reaple with some friends.
Fun!
Fun, fun, fun.
I love Reaple.
Red Griffin, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Thank you!
Yup.
So cute.
Fleet services.
Without this building, we are unable to scale our efforts efficiently.
I'll cut you a deal.
If you insist in the construction of this building, I'll permit the workers to fit your vessel with a significant hole upgrade.
After that, I don't want to see you around here anymore.
Our operation is confidential.
Spank!
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
GM, thank you so much for the 5 gifted.
Thank you guys.
So many gifted.
Thank you.
Get on with it.
Okay.
Fleet services.
Alright.
Construct.
We got to work on the fleet services.
Okay.
466265687542.
The rest is cut off.
Thank you for the 5 gifted!
Did you get the McDonald's?
I didn't get the McDonald's toy.
I was looking at them earlier.
If I get one, I really want the potion.
I think it's the cutest.
GM, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Ducky, thanks for the gifted!
Everything should be operational here, sir.
Excellent.
Remember, fishermen.
I'll permit the workers to upgrade your hull with our tech gear.
But I think you know how this works by now.
You'll have to gather the materials yourself.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
It's raining gifts.
It really is.
How do I upgrade this?
Oh, wait.
Oh, I already... Oh, wait.
Okay, so if I do these...
I've had this scrap here this whole time.
We can get a whole new hull!
Yeah, even bigger hull.
Okay, so we need to get more wood and scrap.
Easy peasy.
We'll focus on that, because I think a new hull...
I think getting these right now would be really great.
To get the tier 5 hull.
Oh, zoo!
Thank you for the 5 gifted!
The meal is kind of expensive, though.
Hope you were able to just get the toys separately.
Is it expensive?
I don't know.
The last time I've had McDonald's.
That's the upgrades I was talking about.
Ah, I see!
Hey, I'm inky.
Random question.
I thought of...
During the karaoke, are there any songs from the Disney Direct-to-DVD sequels you were into?
Are you in or out from Aladdin 3 still pops into my head every so often?
I don't think I... There's an Aladdin 3?
First of all, that's...
It's $15!
11 euro!
Wow.
It sucked.
The only thing I can think of is... And I sometimes quote this, which is so funny.
Pocahontas 2.
Pretty sure that was a Direct-to-DVD.
Oh gosh, how does the song go?
Hold on, let me look it up.
It was?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hold on.
Let me... Hold on.
Pocahontas...
2 songs.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
The song is called Where Do I Go From Here?
But the way she sings it is so silly to me, because she's like...
She's like, where do I go from here?
So sometimes I'll just be like, where do I go from here?
So many voices whispering in my ear.
Dig a tunnel.
Dig, dig a tunnel.
Alright, we need... OK.
Does somebody want to help keep track?
We need 3 wood, 1 scrap.
5 wood, 5 scrap.
What did I... 5 wood... Wait, we were at 5 wood, 5 scrap.
So 8 wood, 7 scrap.
8 wood, 7 scrap everybody.
That's quite a lot.
Oh my god.
Are you OK?
You seem concerned.
Concerned.
No.
Concerned implies...
He turns to look at you.
One of his eyes is bloodshot.
The white completely overrun with dark red blood.
Concerned implies that we didn't know this would happen.
I think the scientist is a little...
Uh-oh.
A fish from Twisted Strand.
OK.
He never asks for these, but then suddenly the quest appears.
Yeah, he's busy.
Alright, we are going to... Wait.
We're going to dock.
No.
We're going to the... Undermarket.
We are going to...
Get our material harvester.
There's nothing in the net, so we can uninstall that.
Take you.
Uninstall here, or install here.
Benton Roy, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh, and we're gonna repair it.
OK.
Now this will be...
Us farming a little bit for...
For some material.
How much did I need?
She's a bit too excited.
Sounds like me.
Hmm.
Alright.
I'm gonna go over to this area first, because I know there was some stuff here.
And then we can go over there.
Just a little bit.
Nice, we got something.
What's this?
Sparkle.
Trophy.
Did I ever find the old mayor?
I'm not quite sure if I did or not.
Luckily, we only need scrap and...
And wood.
Kinda lucked out.
I feel.
Oh, oops.
There we go.
Oh, even more?
Wow.
Ah, shoot.
Kimi, I'm so glad you're back.
Thanks!
I was gone for like three days, guys.
I did mention this in the karaoke, though.
The next couple of months are...
Quite busy for me, so...
Fortunately, there will be...
More time off than I'm off doing things.
I apologize in advance.
That was so close.
Go do big things.
Some of them are big things, so...
I always wish, though, that I could like, you know...
I mean, obviously, I don't have to keep everything a surprise.
But what's the fun in me being... If I were to be like...
Oh, by the way, guys.
You know?
Like...
Because I would love to be like, I'm going to this place to...
Do this thing or whatever, you know?
So make it be like, oh, you have this to look forward to.
But right now, it's just...
Everything has to be a secret.
Well, it's more fun if it's a secret.
It doesn't have to be.
I mean, I'm on my own.
I don't have to...
You know?
Be held by company.
Whoa, we got a nasty guy.
I think I can fit... Oh, it's been depleted anyway.
My immersion.
What are you talking about?
I'm not spoiling anything.
We don't hear nothing.
It's kind of early, but I'm just going...
I just want to get some of the scrap and stuff put into place.
Something...
Spooky.
Is there anything beyond?
Like, look how much map there is left.
What is up here?
Are they gonna release more DLC or like...
There's nothing up there.
You can go look.
One way to find out.
We could just go check it out for the fun of it, you know?
Wait, is there anything that I can actually complete here?
We can actually complete some of this.
Thank you.
We could get more engine.
Faster, baby.
Faster.
We are speed.
And now we go to the Undermarket.
Then we buy it.
My server.
Oh wait, we can sell.
Oh, repair?
What am I repairing?
Oh, I think my harvester.
Oh wait, what's in my net?
I am speed.
Oh, you guys are worse than me.
You guys are 100% worse.
I didn't even...
I didn't even think that.
Get well soon.
We were possessed.
Sure you were.
Possessed, huh?
I like how I...
Wait, why can't I pick that up?
Weird.
Oh, can we upgrade the foundry?
Oh, still waiting on the delivery.
Ah, we can, we can, we can.
Upgrade the foundry, please.
I think we have another thing we can upgrade too.
Wow, we can just make these now.
We can make refined metal.
Oh my god, that's actually huge.
What?
We can make research parts.
Storage boxes are like everywhere.
Wait, we can make wood.
Wait, wait.
How much was the wood?
Because we need some right now.
It's a storage box, but let's see.
Let's upgrade the factory instead.
Oh, nevermind, I only have one.
Okay, nevermind.
Maybe it's not ideal, but I'm gonna make some wood.
I mean, yeah, I'm gonna make some wood.
Because...
We need that for the blueprints right now.
What was I... Oh.
Here, here, here.
And I'm impatient.
Now for this.
Okay.
Alright, we need two wood and one scrap.
Hello, Minto.
I mean everything I say of my own will.
I'm a carpenter now, call me Sabrina.
Rock instead.
Wrong mind game.
Wait, do I have to...
These are automatic, right?
Modifies the cargo space.
Yeah, let's...
Wait, um...
I think I can add an extra light here.
I have this guy.
It'd be kind of fun to have.
Oh, we can get another!
If I sleep, will he spawn a new one?
I wonder.
Okay.
Undock.
Dropping some pots.
Yeah, I'm gonna drop a pot right here.
Oh wait, actually this would be better.
Vivicorn!
Thank you.
What does it say?
Oh, it says chicken jockey.
It's so stinking dumb.
It's so...
It's just so stinking stupid.
Okay, okay, we got another thing.
Let's head over this way.
Oh,
I was like, what is that?
The music is spooky too all of a sudden.
Why?
Let's grab some more wood.
We need what?
Two wood and one scrap?
Was that it?
Two wood, one scrap.
Yes, okay.
Chicken jockey.
Jockey.
This stinking movie has a hold on everyone right now.
It's pretty funny.
I
don't think
he heard.
That's right, I forgot what this one does.
It pings the fish.
What's that sound?
What was I doing?
Oh, athlete services.
Okay.
What does it want me to install here?
The spookiness is... Oh, it's what we'll gain extra.
Nice.
The spookiness is caused by fatigue and a lack of vitamin C.
Check the net.
Oh my god!
You guys!
That's huge.
We're so close!
New hole soon!
Oh my god, we just got to get one more crate.
Which we might... No, I think I need a scrap.
I was going to say we might be able to make one.
I need a scrap.
Scrap.
New hole.
Though...
We can switch some of the stuff around now.
So let's... Okay.
Uninstall.
Let's put this here.
Install.
There we go.
Let's do that.
And then...
We can put another big guy.
You.
I wonder which way it's supposed to go.
Have a combined fishing speed of 200%!
Nice.
And with that... I think that's like...
So good for what we need.
The factory...
Eventually we'll have to get like this one, right?
Obviously, because the mangrove and coastal...
But we're covering a ton of our bases right here.
Just this.
Someone said to put out flotsams.
Flotsam traps.
But I...
Trying to think.
I'm going to rest.
I did not rest very much, but that's okay.
And we're going to go to that other area over here.
Oh yeah.
Oh, dang it.
That's what I was going to do.
I was going to switch out my net.
You know what?
It's fine for now.
I don't think it hurts to collect just a few more things.
You know?
I can always switch it out over here too.
Into...
Yeah, it's right around here.
Oh wait, we might need the mangrove for this, no?
Think about it.
I was right!
I hate being such a genius.
I hate being so smart.
Here I was, thinking that we were set.
That we were so good.
I guess I'll just leave.
I guess we'll just get some more fish to sell.
Actually...
Let's go see if we can find a crate.
Yeah, exactly.
Let's go find a crate.
Pirate, you and I are on the same wavelength.
Crate, crate, crate...
Thank you!
Dredge!
I didn't need to mark it at all.
I see it right...
Oh, there's two!
Perfect.
Not gonna lie guys, I'm starting to fade a little bit.
In terms of...
awareness.
Is that what are you... In terms of me staying awake.
This game is just too cozy comfy.
Just too cozy comfy for me.
Boing!
Oh my gosh, you can see the...
the flea beam.
It's so cool.
The minto is eeping.
Wait, stop it!
Rocks don't really form out this far, but...
I think rocks are the only thing really for the light, no?
Or does other stuff happen when you are in the dark?
Mysterious.
Mint, have you ever had pho?
You know, if you ate pho everyday, some could say you were a...
a furry.
Oh, it slows down.
Oh, you get mad faster, slows down the panic.
I see.
I see, I see.
Okay, goodbye money!
Upgrade to the fifth tier hall!
Oh, why did I move my stuff around?
It's kind of funny.
I like how I carry these and I never use them.
But...
But, you see here... Wait, let's get this stuff out first.
Oh, we got a little treasure.
You can see...
Oh, I think our...
Our other net...
Wait, where is... Oh, this one.
I won't be able to fit these guys, you know what I mean?
Oh, wait.
I think I can upgrade these now.
Or actually make them, I mean.
Oh, wait!
I only have one goop left!
No!
Wait, is this the mangrove one?
Let me make sure I'm making the right one.
Yes, okay.
Tier four.
Oh, do I... Oh, wait, it's bait refinement?
I would rather...
get the rod first.
I need the anti-tangle line.
I don't think I have that.
Anti-tangle!
Anti-tangle here.
Because we need this for the mission.
Okay.
I'll put... Actually, well...
I can make this one too.
Oh, no, I can't.
We'll put this one in tier four then for now.
It's hard to keep my eyes open.
Oh, my buddy!
I'm broke!
Weren't we over 3k earlier?
We're broke now!
That's just how it be.
Let's install...
you.
And then also, we'll install you.
Nice.
Okay.
We'll sell this little baby fish.
Oh, wrong guy.
Okay.
Generator?
Oh, I guess I could've sold him.
No, I don't think he takes it.
Okay.
Oh, yeah, we do need goop.
I think it's okay.
I think it's okay...
if we...
don't goop for now.
Because we don't need to go to the volcanic area for a bit.
Look at our ship.
The double lights!
Wait, what was shining here?
Did you guys see that?
Was something shining?
No.
Wait, I...
Have I not caught this fish before?
What are you?
Sergeant fish.
Oh, I guess I just didn't recognize.
What do you look like?
Okay, okay.
Now we can get all these bad boys in here.
I'm assuming this is a thing we need.
We're fast.
Hell yeah, we are.
What are you?
Oh.
Arapaima.
Let's see.
Let's check the...
Let's check the pursuits.
What do we need?
Wait.
Twisted strand.
Is that where I'm at?
Yeah.
I don't know at all what we got.
I don't know what we got.
We got...
Boreapsis.
That sounds... That sounds...
Terminal.
I'm gonna...
See if maybe some of these are night time critters.
I'm male.
No.
Here.
Oh, we've gotten this guy.
What are you?
We have not gotten this guy.
Ray mullet.
Why am I getting normal guys?
I wish I knew what they look like.
Wait.
I think this is... Yeah, this is this guy.
You're fishing the normal bubbles.
You're right.
Cool guys.
I'm really starting to fade.
There we go.
My brain is really starting to...
Starting to close down.
We need some evil fish.
We need some old fish.
They might be evil because they're old, but you know.
I might need to go EEP.
I'm like basically doing 24 hours right now.
We lost an engine, boys.
Let's go fix...
What are you?
Okay, so that's... Oh, dang it.
I didn't mean to get it again.
You are the same thing.
Yes.
Let's go sell some fish.
It was like a...
Boreapsis.
Okay, well I know where he is, so he's pretty easy to get.
We can go search for the other fishies.
I'm just going to sell them all.
I'm not going to lie.
Because we need the money.
We need the money.
And we know where he is.
He's pretty close.
It's a little bit far, but we got this.
Get one more engine.
I think I will once I have more money.
That's the important part.
Is the cost.
Alright, goopy world.
Incoming.
Oh, this looks like a guy.
A little critter.
Critter.
It's really nasty looking.
Indiana Jones music.
It looks like...
I lost it!
That's so sad.
I lost it.
No!
Have you ever fished IRL?
If so, what have you caught?
Honestly, I can't say that I...
Maybe a long time ago, but I don't think I caught anything.
The fish really do fear me.
They really do be fearing me.
They don't want to touch me.
They don't want to do anything.
But I would go fishing if I...
If I could.
If I had the chance to.
I think it would be fun.
This is the...
This is the effectiveness.
I think we are missing the Nipponite.
The weeaboo fish.
Dredge is such a comfy game.
I know.
I think that's why it's put me to sleep.
Not gonna lie.
It's dark here.
A crab.
Might be it.
I'm just gonna get rid of this guy.
This guy.
I'm gonna get...
I'm gonna get this guy right here.
Cause I see him.
You.
Since we sold him before.
OK.
And then I'm gonna go to the...
I'm gonna go to...
The oil rig.
OK.
Very good.
Little guy.
Back to mother base.
Exactly.
Honestly, I'm seeing more benefits to having...
No!
I turned it off!
Did it turn it on?
It turned it on automatically.
I was literally about to say I see more benefits to having the lights off than on.
And then they turned it on for me.
Sleep in game and out of game.
I will.
I'll go to sleep soon.
It is a crab!
It is a crab.
Lights are haunted.
I wonder if this... I'll at least put this out.
I wonder if it will fit him.
We're getting our money back everybody.
Crab.
We rest.
I know I put one out like close to here, no?
Almost positive.
I put one out like...
Right around here.
Oh, it's right there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ewww.
Take all.
And pick up.
Let's go repair it.
So we'll go put these two out.
And then see.
I know I make less money selling to the generator.
Not gonna lie.
I think it's okay.
And repair.
P.A.!
Thank you.
I'm so bad at reversing.
Oh wait, is this great?
Nope, that's fish.
Yeah, I do have plenty of... I do have a lot of money.
We like generate money really easily now.
Hello.
We generate money so easily.
Those fish?
What are you?
Oops.
Until we go broke again.
Hey, but at least we went broke repairing our bevel.
Making it bigger, better, badder.
Okay.
Alright, now we wait.
And...
I think I'm gonna start sucking up some goop.
I'm gonna attempt to suck up some goop.
Did we ever come up with a name for him?
That's a good question.
I don't think we did.
What was I grabbing?
The SS Minky.
I think you only need one more goop.
I think you're right.
But there... I feel like we have to have more goop, no?
Like, or rather...
I feel like...
I don't know.
SS stands for super stinky.
No it doesn't.
There we go.
Okay.
Sucking time!
I think the goop respawns if you...
No!
It wouldn't do that!
Why would it respawn?
That'd be so rude.
Oh, I'm not very good at...
I'm trying.
Oh my gosh.
I don't want the little creepy guys in the goopy tentacles anymore.
I'm sick of them.
I'm sick of it all.
I think though guys, I might need to go to bed soon.
Oh, Minky is tired.
Minky has no thoughts.
Minky can't even form coherent sentences.
Minky!
Thank you for the 20 gifted!
Thank you!
Like, if I were not streaming this game, I would just be quiet.
Like, that's how I would... I would be fine doing that.
Oh, whoops.
Because I'm like, you know...
Having to entertain a little bit.
My mind is just off.
Or rather, it's...
My mind is...
Silent stream.
Yeah, what if I just stop talking for like a couple minutes?
Then we just suck.
I'm gonna keep it in the goop.
Let's go to sleep.
I fear something might happen.
How was that guys?
You got all the goop noises you could wish for.
And we got no goop.
Was nice, yeah?
You like that?
Only... I'm just...
Giant mud crab!
Did he goop me?
Yes, he did.
Will this still work if it's not in the goop?
That's my question.
I guess it's still gonna get what I...
It's still gonna get what I need.
Yeah, okay.
Horseshoe crab!
He's so cute!
I love horseshoe crabs.
I can't see.
Eyes stinking.
They're so cute.
Horseshoe crab best...
Doesn't count as a crustacean.
I mean, it's got the name crab in it.
Otherwise, it's a poser.
Now I'm lucky.
I believe they're invertebrates.
Amphipod.
Isopod.
We're getting all three?
And then someone says it's a crustacean.
We're getting all... we're getting everything.
The consensus is... confused.
Oh my gosh, I drifted just...
They're lizards.
They're dogs.
They are as cute as a puppy, I'll give them that.
Did you know bugs are crustaceans?
Does it depend on the bug or...
Ew!
I got it!
That's the thingy we needed!
Let's go!
Let's head back to the scientist man.
Well, we didn't really make a ton of progress today, but we made some progress for sure.
Oh my god.
I was so close.
Six, I need to crash.
Good night, Dwargo.
Monocle Steve shall point at you.
Your voice seems a bit better from earlier.
I'm all warmed up.
Thank you, good night!
No thoughts, Eepy Minky.
What is your wisdom for today?
If you buy...
slip-on shoes...
you'll never have to tie them.
Sell, sell, and leave.
You're so fast.
I'm gonna go buy another engine.
Reminds me of that line about biting hands...
It's not even close to the same!
Okay guys, I know what I want to do.
I want to...
put in this little specimen.
Is it every time you dock you save, or every time you sleep at a dock you save?
The dock, okay.
Alright, so we get that.
As a fun fact, all insects are crustaceans and supposedly even taste like them if you get rid of the hair and the goop that is in their blood.
Try them sometime.
You know, Big Boss would.
Why is there hair in their blood?
But everybody says that shrimp are just like insects of the sea, basically.
Shrimp is bugs.
Yeah!
Shrimp is bugs!
They're tasty bugs.
Connected to the chamber.
Not yet.
Pure.
We'll need more.
Down deeper!
Outside the executive is talking to the foreman.
We're almost there.
Give it another push.
How much power can we give this thing?
Sir, I don't think we really should.
The executive shoots the foreman a glance, disdain and dismissal, lacing the muscles on his face.
The foreman backs down.
Defeated.
Setting the drill to full power, sir.
Machinery in the drill tower steps into overdrive.
Blurring the air with the sound of gears turning.
Full power?
What's that noise?
Is it the...
Guy is back?
The Leviathan!
As the roar of the giant creature fades, it leaves behind a silence on all that witnessed it.
Faces stare from windows and hands grip railings, trying to process the spectacle.
Boss, that must have been the thing that got all our material shipments.
Now it's coming for the rig!
A murmur of panic begins to rise from the onlookers.
No, we're close now.
And it knows it.
How long will it take for the drill to break through the next layer?
It still has a little ways to go.
But you can't be serious.
Sure, surely.
Not with that thing in the water here.
Our lives are in danger and you want to keep drilling?
Get it done.
The executive turns and walks away towards his office, leaving the foreman shaking his head.
Golly gee, know-it-all executive in an eldritch horror setting, what could possibly go wrong?
I am serious and...
No, call me Shirley.
He's insane.
What the hell are we doing here?
This drill... whatever's down there...
We shouldn't be disturbing it.
It's like shaking.
Fisherman, you've got to help us.
He won't listen to reason.
But perhaps he'll listen to an operational setback.
What do you have in mind?
We can't shut down the drill ourselves, not without repercussions from the corporation following us for the rest of our lives.
But if it were to be damaged by a force of nature or a force of the deep, we'd have no choice but to abandon our positions.
I know it sounds crazy, but if the defenses were to stop operating suddenly, it would leave the drill vulnerable.
Retirement account crashing...
So I've decided to invest in MinkyCoin.
Boo, one okay savings.
Let's go.
Oh, Brian.
MinkyCoin is where it's at, baby.
I'm telling my kids this was the XOF moment.
Wait, wait, wait.
Spoilers.
Yeah, this is XOF.
Please, have a think.
See what you can do.
Okay, we're thinking.
So we got new defenses here.
The defenses are operational, emitting a droning sound that grates at the ears.
You walk to the perimeter of the tower.
One of the electrical panels hasn't been securely fastened.
Open it.
You open the panel.
Inside, a bundle of cables travels from a black box up to the heights of the tower.
The black box has a number of empty slots on the top, one of which has a module inserted into it.
It's labeled FLEE.
Oh yeah, considering this is her invention, perhaps the researcher would have some advice.
Okay.
So we gotta change the frequency.
From FLEE to...
Can it only be four-letter word?
FLEE to...
Beat.
Minky coin investment, hopefully not a rug pull.
Nope.
Minky coin, I'll buy three.
Thank you.
Date?
Oh my gosh, we're gonna date the tentacle monster.
Boob!
Oh,
because of our ship.
I am the super special captain, yes.
Are you okay?
What samples do you want now?
Sea scorpion.
Okay, nice.
Open the stream in here, boob.
You've been here eleven months, Dan.
What else would you expect?
Okay.
I'm gonna undock.
I'm gonna dock, because I'm gonna have it save.
Then I'm gonna undock.
Alright, and what I wanna do before I end today's stream...
How long have I been streaming, anyway?
Two and a half hours.
Sorry it's a bit shorter of a stream.
I'm just so sleepy.
I wanna go into the deep undock.
To the edge of the map, yep.
It's time to go north.
Into the unknown.
Oh, it's getting dark.
Oh, because it's night time.
Maybe I should sleep first.
No.
We're fine, maybe.
But I might need my light.
No.
It's quiet.
What was that?
Oh, we're starting to go crazy.
We're fine.
I should've brought some tea with me.
It doesn't matter if I die here, though.
I don't quite mind it.
There's not even fish here, no?
That was fast.
Quit it.
Right in front of me.
How far are we?
We're almost there.
There's not even fish here.
Almost there.
Nothing's stopping us.
We died!
Thanks for the
game...
Maybe...
Going at night was a mistake, maybe.
That's just an event, though, right?
He's not actually coming for me?
I think that was just an event.
Not the instant karma!
Oh my goodness.
That surprised me.
I'm too happy to continue.
Good night, Leela!
It's okay.
Load last save.
That was funny.
That was so good!
We're pretty much done anyway.
I wanted to see what would happen.
We got chomped.
I thought it was just a little guy who was gonna be like...
Like before!
It's always been an event.
No, we're gonna need a bigger boat.
Silly note to end on.
We made a little bit of progress tonight, so that's good.
That event had some real bite to it.
JW!
Oh my gosh, thank you so much for the 50 gifted.
Thank you!
I just wanna say this has been a very comfy stream.
Thanks for fishing and have a good eve.
Thank you!
I'll have my schedule up for the week.
Probably tomorrow.
But thanks for fishing with me tonight, guys.
Who knows, we'll maybe do another super long dredge stream this week or something.
Have you gone fishing IRL?
I don't think I have.
I think I've gone once before.
Thanks for another dredge stream.
Thank you!
Thanks for making it.
I feel I have maybe like once before, but I don't remember catching anything.
Maybe I should.
I think I would catch the biggest fish in the pond.
But this was fun.
And I'm so sleepy.
So I'm gonna go to sleep.
And I suggest you guys get some rest as well.
Thank you guys for watching.
Thanks for hanging out with me.
I would catch a boot.
This is not Animal Crossing.
At least let me catch a can.
So I can sell it for some...
For like a quarter.
See ya, Minto.
See you!
Otsu... Minto!
Itterasshoi!
Bye bye!
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Bye bye!
Good night!
Bye!